you're welcome to this video playing
chess I pio 1.com Austria okay so plate
you form and we get let's see really
door on oil pills defense pretty do I
some yeah again it's quite popular at
the moment especially in this mitch
mid-level type of firm type of play
mid-level i'm pretty pretty weird what
I'm saying here what I'm trying to say
is not at the absolute top level but
this kind of mid-range players like I am
strength and so on they they they like
to play this this opening at some
leading to to a solid position without
them any bigger memorization needed so
let's see how do i how do you play him
and now I've got some pressure only five
but there's nothing particularly
threatening going on the bishop on c4
sir it looks nice but it's not doing
very much trying to get maybe the Knight
to c4 and see what black is doing maybe
96 coming in in this case I probably
have g3 available I interesting hmm yeah
um putting some pressure on deform okay
so I'm going to to to make this
fianchetto in this way also supporting
the e4 pawn a bit in case of black
capturing on d4 which probably will
happen at some point
marquette you can still play Bishop g7
whoop dat this kind of moves on okay so
we get this this I don't mind that mean
looks like white has a nicely
centralized position okay I don't really
think he wants to play b5 here he wants
to protect the airport right so that you
can play work the aid okay maybe Knight
to f4 I'm sorry yeah that's not doing so
much yeah okay so see for getting a bit
more control over d 5 so that d 5 is not
easily playable now black has some setup
a fairly fairly solid position okay
wants to go to c5 what I have night h5
here attacking g7 it should it should be
a quite quite annoying you really don't
want to play f6 yeah I guess he didn't
really want to but how to hard to avoid
by now okay well his light will come to
see Five that that's nice hmm so how do
i exploit those some light squared
weaknesses yeah Queen over here to h4
something like that would be would be
nice
95 unfortunately always a Texas pawn
okay going to protect that and now let's
see maybe I can use this this path for
the Queen attacking a five in the meat
are so b6 sm he didn't go for that okay
mmm yeah should I play g4 here keeping
the night you're probably yes so I'm Tim
okay going to get to f5 this gets
interesting now Knight to f5 because
after the kid he can hardly keep it on
f5 I mean this is so annoying this piece
and if he takes I take with deep on
which opens up my my bishop from G to
the sem looks like an interesting way to
play f34 94-94 point agency 16
hmm yeah that's not really that great
okay not a move I want okay now is
giving me the pawn & 3 wasn't really
ideal but how do I otherwise keep your
form and now i'm attacking the rook and
the Ponzi 60 winning an exchange yeah
thinks things are not not clear though
because I'm it's not so easy to owner
that this is helpful of course but not
95 is out of the equation you know but i
can i can do to III cover both the
squares it's still not easy but i
thought he could have just kept the
night on c5 which what would have been
totally annoying so now i'm covering
fynd find the next step is doubling on
the deef i'll climb morning to at the
end to get in the exchange zakian on d6
breaking through at least that's my idea
okay that that didn't help on the other
circumstances i can maybe keep the brook
camp two eggs to make an exchange sack
but i need the bishop on everyone for
that at least k route d2 and then to
till then taking icecat 95 okay
okay don't mind you get in the get the
pawn to h5 can can only be helpful we
should be two next and then I need to
get more firepower to the d6 pawn no not
easy but ok the night is here maybe I
could I should relocate the bishop this
is what I'm trying to do getting the
bishop again to e3 at OC 3 sorry that's
not not easy at all to make any headway
here after I've ever take I really don't
see how to to ever get anything you will
just take with the f porn and block
everything off
okay i know i know i'm breaking through
here
yeah that's the GF on black resign yeah
okay was that was really tricky even
after I won the exchange um because the
position is so closed that you have
problems too to make any progress I mean
around here it's probably a it should
probably be should it be a wind maybe
maybe maybe it should but it's not it's
not so so clear-cut how to do it
especially if you are minute down I'm
not a minute number 40 40 seconds at
least well I try to just keep the
position and make a slow progress which
somehow worked out here shouldn't take
really okay rookie 3 is just better and
now I got this and this this really now
should be a win with them lines getting
opened for for the rooks I didn't have a
good position here before he blundered
the exchange around him I mean okay I'm
not and not terribly worse or anything
but it just does not look totally great
iam look at all pawns our own light
squares it's not not ideal but the main
problem was that here I was thinking
that 94 is the threat but he had this
move which was really am really good to
counter check on Ani form so um I was ok
i can't play yeah maybe I can't do that
actually didn't really think about that
move but it's not bad and then look here
and maybe a form that's it's actually
really good for what oh no didn't think
of that all right yeah thanks for
watching